Welcome back everyone this will be my thor love
and thunder full breakdown of the entire movie
easter eggs for everything there were a bunch
of references and obviously things setting up
the future marvel phase four especially the
post-credits scenes so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're doing
a giveaway for imax tickets all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite easter egg or reference from the movie
in the comments careful for spoilers from the
entire movie we'll be talking about everything
just starting at the beginning we'll work our
way through shot by shot talking about easter eggs
and wtf moments as we go along thor is the first
original avengers character from marvel phase one
to get a fourth solo movie in a spin-off franchise
even though next we're actually going to get a
captain america 4 but it's going to be anthony
mackie's falcon version of captain america so
technically not the same character but it is the
fourth film in that spin-off franchise the actual
title of the movie love and thunder is a reference
to gorr's daughter who is named love in the movie
in thor himself who at the end of the film agrees
to take care of her raising her as his own child
together they go on adventures around the universe
saving people in their known as love and thunder
with both of them wielding thor's weapons she
wields stormbreaker now in thor wields mule near
again because jane foster has died and gone to
valhalla the movie's mostly based on the plot from
the gorr storyline in the comics in the mighty
thor's storyline which was the arc where jane
foster became a version of thor then in a very
80s style like lots of 80s references throughout
the film just the entire vibe of the film as well
as the music like all the guns and roses the d.o
all that stuff was pure taika it was kind of meant
to be in the same tone as thor ragnarok like a
super version of ragnarok the reason why love
is able to wield stormbreaker without the power
of the weapon just melting her brain is because
she has the powers of a god the way they explain
this is because it's a side effect of her being
recreated by eternity the cosmic entity there are
a couple big changes with the way they use the
eternity character in the other cosmic entities
i'll explain when we get to that part of the movie
but they basically just say that now she also
has the bonus of having the powers of a god thor
didn't give her any special powers after the
fact she's played by chris emsworth real life
daughter india hemsworth which is why her accent
sounds different from christian bale's accent
the basic intro of the movie like the opening
scene how he gets the necro sword is all meant
to be right out of the comics is pretty close to
a version of the comic book story his family died
then he learned that the gods of his people didn't
care to intervene and he vows his revenge in the
comics he just found two random aliens one gold
and one black that had been locked in battle and
died together one of them holding the necro sword
and he just takes the necro sword from that black
alien its power forms a suit around him allowing
him to leave the planet and then he just goes on
his quest to kill his own people's gods and then
he sets on his quest to kill the rest of the gods
around the universe that's kind of what happens
during the movie like he enters the space where
his gods live in the necro sword calls to him
showing you the dead body of the previous wielder
now one of the things they don't explain in the
movie though is that there are voices coming
from the necrosword that whispered him calling to
him they never fully explain who this is but even
though they explain the necrosword comes from the
shadow realm in the comics and they have all these
shadow beasts that he summons with the necro sword
from the same dimension they could always wind up
tying the powers of the necros or the necro sword
itself to the knoll backstory like they did in
the comics but originally when it debuted in the
comics it was just the plain old necro sword it
didn't have any of that no venom backstory yet the
whole idea with the power of the necro sword it
choosing gorr is meant to be a parallel for jane
foster and milner calling to her also killing her
when she used it the same way that the necrosword
was killing gorr in him using it like the more
both of them use their special weapons the faster
they die one of the big changes from the gorr
storyline in the comics though is his ultimate
plan so ultimately he finds a quicker way to
kill all the gods in the universe and that is the
god bomb he just forces the god of bombs to create
a bomb that will kill all gods in the universe
simultaneously is sort of like his thanos level
infinity gauntlet work around to do everything
in one fell swoop in the movie they basically
use that for the eternity plot he's going to go
to eternity and make a wish and wish that there
are no gods but in the comics eternity doesn't
work like that it's not like a one-time only
used kind of genie situation eternity generally
doesn't get involved in the day-to-day of lesser
beings usually it delegates that to the celestials
and other more powerful cosmic entities and beings
the beings that you see in the temple at the end
are all cosmic entities they're generally meant
to be so powerful that they very rarely ever
get involved in stories don't worry i'll talk
about all them when we get to that part of the
movie because there are some really cool easter
eggs and references there there were a couple big
deleted scenes early in the movie that christian
bale revealed he said that when gorr's daughter
dies he said there was a scene of him howling this
primordial scream like blood curling scream that
marvel just said no way you're putting that in
the movie it's just way too freaky and there was
a scene of him mutilating his own body to remove
all the religious tattoos that's why later in the
film you see all those scars all over his head all
over his face in his body is because he mutilated
himself to remove all those religious markings
marvel also said too gruesome not putting that
in the movie the movie itself was only about two
hours long so it was actually really short for a
typical marvel movie natalie portman also revealed
there's a ton of deleted scenes so i'll point them
out when we get to those parts of the movie when
they were featured later when they're looking at
all the distressed signals and you find out what
happened to sif and falagar the other really giant
rat looking god there's a scene of gods being
strung up and killed that's meant to be gorr's
people's gods in the comics the new marvel intro
that they use in this movie is the same one that
we've been watching in the miss marvel episodes
it has moon knight in it and it has some doctor
strange two scenes usually every time there's like
a brand new big marvel movie they updated just a
little bit with new scenes from the previous film
they do play a custom metal version of the
marvel studios fanfare music because there's
this whole 80s metal music vibe through the
entire movie they don't actually name the
planet of the blue aliens that they go to at the
beginning of the film but the king is named yacon
yondu's arrow is called the yaaka arrow which
now belongs to kraglin along with his finn so
closest connection i could think to these blue
aliens would be yondu's people the centaurians
but i don't actually think that the centaurians
because their faces do look a little bit different
taika watiti explains that the present day of the
film takes place about three years after avengers
end game so it's about 2026 during the events of
the movie which would make it the latest in marvel
phase four that we've been so far in the timeline
not including the loki series because that's like
billions of years later at the very end of the
timeline they show a brief flashback montage to
just explain what's been happening with thor since
avengers end game with some enya music he's been
hanging out with the guardians of the galaxy they
show him losing all the weight they have a bunch
of jokes while he's going through the workout
montage you don't ever find out who the skeleton
of the alien is the proportions of the head to the
body aren't quite right for it to be one of the
watchers but based on how big the dwarves are it
could be a dwarven skeleton the hat he's wearing
says strongest avenger that he wrote in sharpie
himself it's meant to be a big callback to thor
ragnarok with a joke about him being stronger than
the hulk the actual front of the hat though the
logo is meant to be in the classic avengers comic
book art font saying earth's mightiest heroes
they show a couple flashback scenes of thor as a
child being carried into battle with a tiny sized
hammer it's not meant to be mjolnir it's just like
a regular tiny hammer the woman is also supposed
to be just a random asgardian warrior woman it's
not his mother frigga or a member of the valkyrie
because by this point the valkyrie had already
been killed off except for valkyrie herself
they have a short montage of thor growing up
through the different ages because he's about
1500 years old in present day the youngest version
of thor here little kid thor is actually played
by chris hemsworth's real life son natalie
portman's children taika watiti's children
and christian bale's children were all also in the
movie natalie portman and taika watiti's kids were
in the group that were stolen by gorr and then
christian bale's kids because they're a little bit
older i think that they were featured in all the
scenes in new asgard with all the tourism stuff
the teenage version of thor is wearing a
version of the classic jack kirby costume
like the original thor costume with the old
school comics the gold boots the gold highlights
later he brings that back for his ravager's
version of the uniform this version of the suit
is meant to be right before the first thor movie
the joke about his wolf woman girlfriend i think
is meant to foreshadow the lycan children living
in new asgard which itself is more foreshadowing
for vampires and werewolves showing up in the
werewolf by night halloween special later this
year and during the blade movie with vampires next
year the large wolf that they're also doing it on
might also be a reference to the same race as the
wolves that hella's cosmic wolf fenris comes from
which is also itself from norse mythology when
they're talking about thor's relationship with
jane foster they show some dark world footage they
have jokes with core getting her name wrong first
he calls her jane fonda then later he calls her
jody foster they have a couple jokes about the
other warriors three that died during ragnarok
saying this guy this guy this guy like they can't
be bothered to learn their names he also jokes
about loki's three different supposed deaths
just to clarify this is original loki that was
killed by thanos and he's meant to be perma dead
that time so like jane foster goes to valhalla at
the end of the film in this alternate dimension
she could speak to a version of loki he would be
there he mentions heimdall's death to foreshadow
heimdall's cameo in the post-credits scene they
don't explain who these robots are in this one
flashback scene where they're fighting on a
different planet but if you think you know who
they are write their name in the comments below
when he plants stormbreaker in the ground near
the tree they reveal that because it's made from
groot's body a lot of you've had this theory in
the past that it continues to grow over time like
the axe is kind of alive because that part of the
axe is alive at least that's why when he rips
it out of the ground it's already grown roots
they had this running gag during the film where
stormbreaker kind of gets its own teenage group
kind of storyline like they had that during
the avengers movies in the guardians of the
galaxy movies where baby groot grows up and
becomes this really mouthy version of a teenager
because technically stormbreaker is meant to be
a teenager so to speak during the film at least
the way that taikawati explains it is supposed
to be kind of similar during the film because
they have this weird love quadra angle between
thor stormbreaker natalie portman's jane foster
and mjolnir like thor has had relationships with
all these different people the way he treats the
hammer in the axe is that they're both alive but
even though they've been kind of ambiguous about
this in the movies in the comics the hammer is
actually alive it actually possesses the soul of
this cosmic sentient storm that's trapped inside
it so like the hammer itself eventually does wind
up speaking literally to jane foster during her
arc when she becomes mighty thor they have a joke
about thor looking kind of like a witch riding
on stormbreaker like you would write on a broom
as he flies to help the guardians of the galaxy
into the blue aliens they don't actually name
the bird aliens that they're fighting but the way
they look they look kind of like muppets from the
labyrinth movie in the movie all the guardians
of the galaxy all get new costume upgrades
groot is only a tiny bit bigger but he's still
a teenage group pretty much the same personality
star-lord's costume is yondu's jacket basically
like he's been wearing yondu's jacket but he's
upgraded with a lot of the costume designs from
ego the living planet so he has a bunch of metal
pieces on it all the designs look kind of like
celestial designs like he's accepted his origin
story that ego was his father they revealed thor's
ravager costume is just a combination of a bunch
of asgardian themed easter eggs it's meant to
be a version of eric masterson's thunderstrike
80s costume from the comics which is why he
looks kind of like construction worker thor
he's got the gold boots from the classic thor
costume he's got the world tree looking tank
top t-shirt which is also meant to be an easter
egg for kurt russell's t-shirt during big trouble
little china who also did play ego the living
planet during guardians of the galaxy 2. he also
has an asgardian belt buckle but i don't think
it's meant to be his special belt that doubles
his strength in the jacket is basically just like
a ravager's jacket that he's cut up and repurposed
the aliens also have this joke where they call him
the god of destruction even though he's the god of
thunder because he destroys their sacred temple in
trying to save it but when he goes on the attack
they start playing guns and roses welcome to
the jungle from the appetite for destruction
album there's a couple songs in the movie from
that album and some separate guns and roses songs
they also play sweet child of mine paradise city
and november rain november rain is the one from
a different album axel rose probably got a sweet
check from this movie and speaking of axel rose
heimdall's son astrid is now calling himself
axel inspired by axel rose from actual guns n
roses when he does the splits between the vehicles
that's also meant to be a van damme joke but it's
also a reference to the commercial that van damme
did where he did the splits between a couple 18
wheelers which itself was meant to be a parody
of himself doing the splits in all of his movies
so it's like a parody of a parody there a couple
jokes about thor just wearing out his welcome
like he jokes about them helping out when
really thor doesn't actually need their help
like he doesn't need to be with the guardians for
physical help he's there more for emotional help
like they show him crying a lot when he's
hanging out with star-lord james gunn did
supervise all these guardians of the galaxy
scenes he did have a lot of input here and
a lot of times when the guardians do show up in
somebody else's film like all the avengers films
james gunn will oftentimes write the dialogue
for them they show jane foster getting her chemo
cancer treatments that's right out of the mighty
thor comics arc in that she had breast cancer and
mjolnir was killing her faster because when she
wielded it its power burned all the chemo out
of her body allowing the cancer to grow faster so
that's how she dies quicker the more she uses it
they have cameo scenes from darcy and eric selvig
this is set after one division so darcy's already
been through the events of that series she's still
working as a researcher eric selvik also doing
the same research he was doing the first two thor
films eric selvig has also been mentioned several
times in other marvel movies he's since written a
bunch of books and starred in a nova movie which
itself was meant to be a clever reference to the
nova character eventually it seems like marvel is
going to give us a nova series on disney plus they
also just mentioned eric selvig's name on the miss
marvel series when talking about his research
into wormholes between dimensions they revealed
jane foster has also published a book about her
research into wormholes called the foster theory
which love is reading on thor's ship at the end of
the movie when she references event horizon that
starred sam neal and lourdes fishburne both mcu
actors now sam neil is the fake version of odin
and lawrence fishburne is goliath she also
references interstellar by christopher nolan
basically trying to explain science as people
believe it as magic kind of like a reverse of what
happened during the first thor from that was what
it was meant to be a callback to thor explaining
everything to her darcy also makes a space viking
reference talking about thor this time but later
in the movie they also bring it back around what
korg calls jane foster mighty thor a space viking
talking about the statue that they built for her
but instead of hearing an actual voice like gorr
hears from the necro sword she just hears the
ringing sound that mjolnir makes when it flies
through the sky but that's what gives her the
idea to use the power of mjolnir to try and
heal her cancer because she sees that it can make
people stronger and purge their bodies of sickness
obviously the research seems like it's misguided
it doesn't exactly go that way like it literally
is too much for her body they play the guns n
roses paradise city song when she goes back to
new asgard and they reveal that valkyrie in a
bid to try and make more money for her people
has basically turned it into a version of disney
world like this is a disney movie so they kind of
make a bunch of disneyland disney world jokes with
everything just being commercialized and turned
into this big touristy destination they even have
jokes about them doing commercials for products
too like they even shot a funny tie-in ad with
fake thor played by chris hemsworth's real-life
brother luke hemsworth for old spice but this
is why there are so many puns all over the place
like they christened a new store called infinity
cones themed after thanos and the infinity
gauntlet selling regular ice cream the goat boat
is an actual ship that they use for tours the
neon sign is actually an easter egg for the tom
cruise cocktail movie it's called the agir which
literally means the sea one of the local bars is
called the black raven named after odin's black
ravens they revealed that meek is using a cyborg
body and that he is a she it's a female office
worker uniform she dresses in she's just been
helping valkyrie out the way they explain valkyrie
is that she's also really bored at the day-to-day
of being queen like she really really wants to go
back to just being a female warrior with the other
valkyrie she really misses the valkyrie core that
died off when they tried to kill hella so during
the movie she thinks of jane foster's thor is
kind of like one of her sisters they have another
funny play this time parroting the events of thor
ragnarok odin's death in hella breaking thor's
hammer to set up the jane foster mule near twist
and the twist with her dying and going to valhalla
at the end of the movie they brought back matt
damon as fake loki luke hemsworth as fake thor
and sam neal as fake odin in this time they cast
melissa mccarthy as a version of hela after gorr's
attack they also bring back matt damon and luke
hemsworth for funny cameo scenes where the actors
are begging valkyrie to put on another play based
on the events of gorr's attack like the people
need entertainment we should put on another play
you also notice they've erected special shrines
at the site where odin actually died on the cliff
face like right where he died they have daryl
from the thor ragnarok team thor funny short
giving tours they also have a joke about how they
created the shrine for the pieces of mule near on
the site where hella broken like this is literally
the site where it broke because of the enchantment
nobody could move the pieces because no one was
worthy so they literally just lifted the ground
up and built the shrine around it there's a joke
about that too it's meant to be a reference to
the joke at the end of avengers age of ultron
about the elevator lifting the hammer in the
elevator not being worthy then there's actually
a big deleted scene here where jane foster
gets the power of mule near the hammer reforms
i don't know why they deleted it they probably
powerful enough to destroy the enchantment on it
so when jane foster comes close to it it's the
power of the enchantment that reforms the hammer
and all of her armor comes from the enchantment
her armor is meant to be a combination of comic
book mighty thor armor sivs armor and then classic
thor's armor because thor's like your dress like
a version of me then thor gets his two goats from
the comics tooth nasher and tooth grinder but
in the comics they're not actual ghosts they're
just like cosmic animals that help him fly through
space when he needs to get around places and he's
become unworthy in the movie though they explained
that they belonged to these blue aliens before and
they're kind of dumping them on thor like it's
not meant to be a gift it's kind of a curse
the big joke being that they suck and they
just scream a lot mostly the goats are used
for comedy like what you see in the trailers
is basically the way they use them in the movie
james gunn also revealed that the goats themselves
would come back during the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special this christmas that's meant to be
like a prequel to guardians of the galaxy 3 so it
will be canon to the mcu i'll do a video for that
when they release a trailer but we probably won't
get that till way later this year kraglin comes
back he's wearing yondu's fin and they reveal that
he's been marrying locals on every single planet
that they've gone to in the last couple of years
then in the scene when they're revealing all the
different distress calls they have a bunch of
different scenes are meant to be comic book
references to a bunch of pantheons of gods
that gorr has already killed like all these are
different gorr kills that we don't see during the
movie natalie portman also said that there were
tons of deleted scenes and whole worlds that they
cut out of the movie i think a lot of those scenes
were just showing gorr's path of destruction
showing him actually killing some of these other
gods also they explained there was a deleted scene
with the grand master and with etre the dwarf and
they made it sound like that was brand new scenes
that we hadn't seen before so i think they would
have also shown up in this montage or maybe during
the flashbacks when they're talking about what
thor's been doing this whole time the dead god
where thor finds sith now minus one arm is falagar
god of the faligarians right out of the comics he
was actually thor's friend he's the person that
kind of makes him realize what a threat gorr is
and then they have the funny scene where thor
says goodbye to star-lord and the guardians of
the galaxy the handshake that just goes on forever
taikawati also said there's a deleted scene here
where they just did more and more handshake
like it just keeps going on and on and on
the snake you cannot trust move i think is meant
to be a reference to loki in the world serpent
later we also find loki tattooed on thor's back
the second costume upgrade the thor has is right
out of the comics the third costume upgrade
the blue gold armor is like a version of his
battle armor and the rune king thor armor with
a crazy big helmet wings when we catch up with
sif she also gets another costume upgrade which is
based on her comic book armor they have a couple
valhalla jokes to explain how you actually make it
there to set at the end of the movie and then when
they go back to new asgard they have that funny
moment during gorr's first attack where thor sees
mjolnir for the first time and he sees jane foster
for the first time as another version of thor so
the way they explain the mechanics of this is that
he's still worthy he can still pick up the hammer
it's just that the hammer has temporarily chosen
jane foster as his main wielder so it obeys her
commands first in battle and if she were to die
during some other battle then it would answer his
call that's why at the end of the film after she
dies he's able to wield it like he normally would
they have a bigger flashback to explain why they
broke up this is all right after the ending of
thor the dark world and it sounds like their
relationship only lasted for a little while before
going their separate ways because when he says
they've been separated for over eight years that's
basically like right up to the end of dark world
but the joke with her thinking it's only been a
couple years i think is meant to be a reference
to her being snapped like she missed five years of
her life which is why it seems like eight years
to thor but closer to like three years for her
they have a couple funny moments here too about
thor's relationship with the hammer like they
use the hammer to go rollerblading together they
also pay that off later when thor's like are you
still rollerblading i've been rollerblading a
little bit then the reason why gorr can pick up
stormbreaker is because it doesn't have that same
worthiness enchantment on it that the hammer does
even thanos is able to pick up stormbreaker during
avengers end game and use it to try and kill thor
valkyrie joins them wielding odin's spear
which thor gave her when he gave her the title
she's also riding her winged horse aragorn in
the comics the black knight kate harrington's
character actually gave her that horse obviously
in the mcu it's an ancient horse that was given
to her by odin a long time ago so it's a little
bit different backstory they have a joke about
it being a portal horse the joke is is that it
can open portals across space like the bifrost
later in the movie that's how jane foster gets
back to eternity you notice in the town hall
the next day when they're all meeting valkyrie
is wearing a phantom of the opera t-shirt i've
already explained heindel's son astrid the reason
why he can contact thor across space is because he
has all the same powers that heimdall did that's
also why his eyes glow the same way that heimdalls
do one of heimdall's big abilities in the comics
though is literally just farsights he can see
anything across the universe as long as he
focuses on it so like he can't see everything
simultaneously all at once you'd have to
tell him what you're looking for and then
he'd be able to find it when thor's talking about
omnipotent city and the gods he mentions a couple
specific really powerful ones raw the leader of
the pantheon of gods that konchu comes from that
we saw on moon night he's actually meant to be
conscious father in the comics also called amit
we also see boss the panther goddess later in
the film that's the goddess that black panther
and the people of wakanda worship she's meant
to be conscious sister also the daughter of ra
he mentions hercules setting up the cameo scene
in the post-credits scene also kind of letting
you know that he thinks of hercules as being one
of the most powerful gods thor and hercules have
a long history in the comics hercules is a huge
marvel character so i'll talk about him a little
bit more when we get to that part of the movie he
mentions tome toanga quits a cowatal the aztec god
the people in the mcu at one time actually believe
that ajax the eternals character was a version of
that god when really it is an actual god this
also kind of connects to black panther too the
reason why they're doing so much stuff with
the mcu gods in moon knight and now in thor
love and thunder is to help set up black panther
2 where we see a version of namor who also forms
a contract with one of their people's gods the
same with a black panther has a contract with
boss the panther goddess i just did a really big
black panther 2 first look video explaining that
and what his god tier avatar form looks like
so i'll link that below in the description
then when he starts talking about zeus the way
they play mcu zeus is that he's the leader of
the godhead and thor claims that he's the
oldest god who's still alive in the mcu
the godhead and omnipotent city are both right out
of the comics the godhead is like a congregation
of the most powerful gods it was featured during
the thanos infinity gauntlet storyline they don't
meet that often they play in the movies a little
bit different omnipotent city comes right out of
the gorr comics storyline in the history of that
place is that it was actually created by a group
of elder gods after they had this ancient version
of an avengers endgame god tear situation just
fighting with each other until most of them had
been killed off the survivors of the battle called
the truce creating omnipotent city as this place
of fellowship to mark the truce and it basically
just served as this meeting place of all the
most powerful gods during the gorr storyline thor
travels there just looking for more information
about gorr the god butcher but the way they use
it in the movie is in a slightly more comedic more
crazy way but just anybody can't travel there like
the normal avengers couldn't go there if they
wanted to they'd have to have thor with them who
brought them there although after the movie maybe
not so much now because it seems like the rest of
the gods kind of hate thor now and when they
actually travel to the city there are hundreds
hundreds of gods in the background here you could
spend hours just picking through all them zooming
and enhancing trying to spot the ball if we
had a high enough rez version of the movie
they only referenced a couple of them directly
like the emotion gods basically they're gods for
like every single concept every single culture in
the universe that's why there's so many of them
there's a dragon god which seems like more of a
shang shi reference to the great protector cosmic
dragon from that alternate dimension there's the
god of magic the god of dreams which is a giant
eyeball the god of carpentry is actually meant
to be a joke about jesus but like they have bow
the god of dumplings a giant dumpling that was
actually meant to be a reference to the pixar
short movie also called bow about the dumpling
boy that is one delicious looking god right there
they show the cronin god of korg's people the joke
where he says hey nini nani is actually a song
that taikawati wrote for the movie and then sings
on the goat boat later basically the song's just
about getting it on i also think his throne is
meant to be a big game of thrones iron throne joke
because it's made of a bunch of pairs of scissors
like the iron throne is made of a bunch of melted
swords you notice in the background they also
have a couple of giant celestials not because
they're gods like they're not gods they're just
really powerful cosmic beings you find out that
zeus calls his thunderbolt thunder thor is the
god of thunder and they make a couple of jokes
about him being very similar to zeus like i i
bet you've probably detected i based a lot of
myself on him like he's the god of lightning i'm
the god of thunder and i believe at the end of the
movie they don't give him thunder back like they
still have his lightning bolt weapon at new asgard
on the goat boat when they're escaping thor
references zeus and the other gods hunting
them down for the rest of their days that's just
meant to be a reference to the post credit scene
where zeus sends hercules after him declaring
war on all the avengers and all superheroes korg
references thor being a dad having a baby meant
to set up this twist with him raising gorr's child
and in the comics during the gorr storyline they
did reveal thor's three daughters so eventually
he does have daughters in the comics gorr is able
to steal stormbreaker from thor as they bifrost
back to new asgard because there's no worthiness
enchantment on it so he can literally just pick it
up and uses that to summon the doorway where
eternity is so like the temple has at least
seven cosmic entities inside it there's eternity
itself the living tribunal the watcher some of
you think this celestial is the prime celestial
there's death eon and infinity i've already done
longer videos explaining who all these cosmic
entities are but like death for instance was
from the thanos infinity gauntlet storyline
eternity is meant to be the living embodiment
of everything in the universe like the actual
mcu itself so when they actually travel into
this cosmic place in the center of the universe
where it actually exists it's kind of like them
looking at themselves because they're looking
at the actual universe that's why its body is
the star field you also notice on the doorway
where the bifrost is meant to open the portal
the symbol is the same symbol that the bifrost
burns into the ground every time that it opens
when thor grants the power of thor to all these
children that's just meant to be a wink at the
thor core from the secret wards arc with many many
versions of thor at once they explained that after
jane foster comes back using valkyrie's winged
horse in the portals she destroys the necrosword
like it disintegrates into nothingness and lots
of you asking what jane foster whispered to thor
before she died she was suggesting a new
catchphrase and he was just responding her
saying oh that's the best one yet so you can post
all your theories what you think her catchphrase
was i've already explained how gorr brings his
daughter back using his wish to eternity and
how they kind of changed that from the comics in
the comics eternity doesn't really work like that
but it is meant to have night omnipotence
inside the mcu like it has control over all time
and all space so it can do things like that
it could bring a version of his daughter back
when they go back to asgard they reveal the
statue to mighty thor valkyrie starts training
all the different children sif with her one arm
starts training heimdall's son korg pays off the
joke about the way that their race reproduces in
the volcanoes with this new person that it seems
like he's going to have a child with and they
just have a bunch of jokes with thor being dad
to gorr's child like a bunch of father-daughter
jokes just like casual like they're regular people
she's reading jane foster's book she draws all
over thor's hammer it's just meant to be annoying
things that little kids do i've already explained
the title sequence thor love and thunder like the
actual name of the movie but then they have this
very 80s themed end credits sequence with all the
different names done in 80s album fonts i just
posted a much longer post-credits scene video
about both of the big post-credits scenes the
first one was zeus and hercules then declaring
war on the avengers i'll post a link to that at
the end of this the second post-credits scene
is jane foster going to valhalla i also discussed
that during that separate post-credit scene video
but the idea is that yes she can come back like
she's just existing in a different dimension
we just saw a version of that happen during the
moon night series just because you go to this
alternate dimension doesn't mean that you can
never come back but if there were any easter
eggs or references or big questions that you
have from the movie that i didn't address in the
video just write them below in the comments
even though it was a short movie you could
re-watch it like a hundred times and still find
new easter eggs and references in the background
i will do some more bonus videos for the movie
but the real big thing that's coming up is marvel
comic-con they're supposed to be dropping the
black panther 2 trailer so when that releases of
course i'll do new videos for that they're also
bringing the new x-men animated series episodes
and what if season 2 and some other animation
stuff to comic con so there'll be a bunch of
big trailers in the next couple weeks everyone
click here for my full thor love and thunder post
credit scene video and click here for my brand new
black panther 2 first look video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!